So we're going to go pretty much just straight into November, cool.
So first of November, we have interest rates, jobs, ISM, a lot of
news, but that's in New York, so we're looking for shorts.
I'm not going to get those shorts.
New York session probably isn't a good idea to trade, to be honest with you.
And this is also, this is interest rates, I remember correctly, it's not a good
look, not great.
Share Polish, second of November, cool, need to see a sweep of those lows, nope
.
It's a really weird one, that's technically a swing low.
Yeah, I'm not going to get a trade on that day.
Third of November on a Friday, that would be NFP.
Yep, I'm not going to trade, we're not going to trade New York.
We're missing out on some great opportunities here, still bullish. Oh wait,
when did that happen?
Okay, happened over the weekend, first of November.
So everything needs to go forward an hour.
I'm going to do this six, surely I have some more of a retracement now.
Continuation is long, we're not going to be able to trade off that in London.
New York, go trade.
We're not going to be able to trade that, because I'm never going to use that
as my swing high.
I don't really see the purpose of price running above those highs to be honest
with you,
which doesn't really make sense.
Didn't think so, continuation bearish, this one's high, no trade so far from
November.
Needs to run that high, and guess what? Now we're bullish.
Okay,
Thursday, the 9th, Fedpal.
One second of I was missed a trade in there.
Nope, and nope.
Still bullish, but okay we don't have any news right now.
Spring is back, is there a one minute shift here?
For me, I would use the internal inverter by go.
Exactly one to five, give or take.
Nice, very nice, that's a low New York continuation right?
No, you're a New York vessel, nope.
Comes from, is that actually a broad point of interest?
Yeah, sorry, it's a New York. Structure flow, there isn't really one.
Trend is a change of character. There was no news.
Clean trade, New York has been really powerful in terms of its efficiency.
It's been extremely efficient. Oh, what a trade as well by the way.
Um, we're bearish, Friday the 10th of November.
We have christening the guard's speech, but that's in New York.
So we're still good to go for shorts.
That's going to indicate a reversal. For sure. Well, not for sure, but highly
likely.
Nope.
No changing character. Sometimes, sometimes M1 confirmation is just good.
No, no reversal. Oh, wait.
It's not true, already bearish. Okay.
Technically, we could short this, but it's one of those trades that I don't
like again, isn't it?
We have the reversal here. New York opens continuation, but it's so far down in
the price leg.
So it's like, in theory, I have to trade from here,
but it's one of them again. Like, I don't like the reversals.
We spoke quite a hundred times, but we don't like those.
Can I just?
So. Okay.
So.
That's my mistake.
I've got lucky with that.
Because I forgot that at seven,
seven, 30, exactly. Christine Lagarde's beach. And so we got lucky.
Yeah. But we may not get so lucky again. I think we have a reentry here.
But this is a better low reversal for me.
Like, I want the low reversal when price is gap here was mitigated.
When price is back to the area of law, but then again, we have now we have
relative equal highs.
We do have news. So we ought to be careful about that.
But it's a 10 Michigan consumer, which can have to manage this aggressively.
But I think I think we just seem to already go to break even pretty quickly.
Which is a good thing.
So it's like 830. Take that from a 1% down to a 7.7.
Down to .4.
To the reaction. 4.32 down to a break even.
I don't want to hold it for the news to be totally honest with you.
It's 1 to 7. Great.
But really good management.
This is a low. What is this?
Because low sweeps in the reverses, but then we come back to bullish and then
we shift again.
So what is that?
But we'll consider it a low turn.
Back to London.
Even if there was a re-entry, which it looks like there was after we got
stopped out.
It looks like price after our re-entry. Sorry, not after our re-entry.
After our unfortunate departure from the market,
there was an opportunity to trade. But honestly...
I'm not going to see here and tell you that I would trade that.
Because I don't know that I would like it. It would be extremely ballsy of me
to sit here and say
that I would trade this with that level of perfection. It would be extremely
ballsy.
And even if I did, I still wouldn't have made him. I wouldn't have been break
even.
With knowing that there was news coming out at 10, and my entry was at 9.42.
Not a chance.
Behave. Behave. Monday. Zesser teams.
We have no news apparently.
Is it? Could it be possible?
Possible it may, but actual. It shall be not.
Apologies if I'm slouching in my germ. Tired.
Well, well, well, would you look at that? It would appear.
That I would need to check this mouth. First bearish. Second bearish. Third
bearish.
Wait. Is that even a thing?
I don't think I've ever seen that before.
Where the third bearish candle comes after but doesn't continue lower.
I wouldn't worry about it too much if that's something that's going to happen
to you.
Often, that's the first one I've ever seen it.
Well, where would, where would one, into such market?
Where would one, into such a market? I think one would probably enter
that market. Like this.
But I don't like that M15 wick.
Don't like that M15 wick at all.
But we shall trade the plan.
And it's not deviate. Regardless of what may happen.
And this is a scenario where you would like, I would like to move my wrist like
this dynamically.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, get back up there before you get me in trouble.
And, oh, golly gosh, I would really like to go to break even actually.
You couldn't have pushed it down a tick more.
You couldn't have pushed it down a tick more for us.
100% though, like the dynamic management on this is like price tags in.
We trade out, I move my stop loss.
This goes from a 1% loss to a 0.2%, 0.25%. No, not even that 0.18%.
But that shall, that shall be some very long ass work that I would have to do.
Declare the data. But I may be able to get the help of some friends.
Drop me a DM. If you're watching this, drop me a DM.
Actually, I'm probably not because by the time you watch this,
I may have already finished it and then everyone will be a DM.
I mean, you've got something that doesn't exist.
So, hold that for. Thank you very much.
A London sweep, Frankfurt,
from a broad point of interest in the London session, where they counter trend.
The execution window is three to four.
OK, let's keep it rolling.
Well, thanks for that.
Oh, would you look at that? We're still bearish.
That wasn't funny, wasn't it?
OK. We have very aggressive New York, but I'm not so aggressive London session.
Hold your horses. Hold your horses. I think we have a trade.
OK, apologies if I'm annoying.
And then one of those weird moods where it's like late
and you just kind of do it everything you can to just keep yourself going.
I'm sure you can relate. Honestly, why am I taking the trade from there?
What's the context?
Why? Why that specific level? That's why everybody wants to know.
This is the cluster.
This is the sweep. That's like the middle finger, quite literally.
Like range, sweep, yeah, goodbye. I could literally look at it. It's a middle
finger.
And that's basically what they're trying to do.
So we'll cover the high, but the reality is, as it pro trades above this, it's
definitely
going to trade above this. I should stop saying definitely.
So flamboyantly. I hope that's right word, because the reality is,
is that I don't actually know anything in the entirety of reality that is
definite.
So that's the one thing I'm definite about. I definitely not definite.
Oh, you got a lot of the paradoxes of reality, hey? Well, we get tagged in.
And we do get the very quick opportunity to move our stops, and you can quite
clearly see
here that we could have actually probably had to stop us here. But at the same
time,
having to stop us at that high enables us to reduce risk.
You know what's going to happen? Let me just call it here first, right? Here's
what's going to happen.
Price is going to tag us out with a small loss.
And then what I'm going to do is I'm going to check if I would have been my
stop plus here,
and my five R would have been here. It would have tagged me.
I don't worry about that. Still got some good risk reduction. And as you can
see,
if this high goes, this high goes. Okay, that was in London,
sweet pager. I've taken a lot of trades in this November. London, sweet pager,
from a strong point of interest, may I add, during the London session, when the
structure flow was
quite vividly counter trend, and we were in the phase of changing character,
and we were in a
premium discount, and there were not any news. And the execution window was
precisely
between the hours of two and three AM. We followed all of our rules.
All of the rules, thank you very much. And we proceed to walk away with nothing
.
Okay.
How would you look at that? Thanks for that.
Thanks for that.
Well, better the next time, eh? Try again, shall we?
And for some reason, I just feel like we're really trying not to trade that law
.
It's a really chopping market.
And the time is four or five, we get tagged in, and would you look at that, we
get
to show you how. Thank you very much. Okay.
London, doeth, sweep, thou Asia, with thou internal, trending against us.
Thus, it is, we are on the premium of the discount.
And thou shalt execute thou trade at exactly four, ten AM.
On a Tuesday. Thank you, Sire. Okay. We have a lot of news coming up.
We just shifted, Balash. I'm just gonna buy. I'm just gonna buy from here.
I'm gonna put my stop loss right here. And I'm gonna target up here. Watch this
.
Oh, the irony of that is actually pretty funny.
That's pretty funny. I have to keep myself sane somehow. Well, there's no way I
'm
this earth that I am going to be able to get a trade in the back of that. So we
shall go to 15th
of November. We've got a bit of pullback off the back of that. Surely I'm going
to try
along here and I'm going to get absolutely annihilated. Because, I mean, talk
about overextended.
Well, just know I called it first. Just know I called it first. I know that's
what's happened.
Well, we may have saved ourselves. Or may not, who knows.
But the M1 structure is bearish. Which means, legally, I'm not allowed to take
this trade.
Sometimes this magnet can be quite the return. So legally, the swing height is
here.
So I'm technically not allowed to take this trade. I'm watching this now
somehow. Be a profitable
trade. Oh, no. Excuse the dog. Let's have a look at this, shall we?
So that's not. But that is. And we have inverted, how are you going?
The question is, is the, does it go higher first or lower first?
This is really weird. I don't usually do this.
As you can probably imagine. But I need to see.
Okay. Okay, so it happens after. Thanks for the insight.
But then, what do you trade to? What probably here?
I don't think it taxes anyway.
Before I put the order on.
Okay, cool.
maybe New York, and Detroit away from that level didn't it?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Hang on a second.
Upon the shift of down low, the bell can confirm there is no trade.
And here we are in London session.
That's going to shoot up.
Why does everything sounds like a laggy? Come on, New York.
Thursday, the sixteenths.
Come on, I don't want to reset the, I don't want to set the indicator up again.
I'm going to have to set the indicator up again, aren't I?
Trade's Ella, you need to do something about this because it's really annoying.
Although it may be set up now.
Okay, that should be solved.
Yeah, unfortunately, no trade.
Come on, we're not doing this.
Oh.
The issue that I'm having is objectively speaking.
This here is a technical for that candle.
Because there's no pullback that we can use.
Like zero. How to wait for all the way up here.
We can flag it as with you, but I'll give the context.
The thing is, is we may be able to get away with trade in you.
This is a little bit of a sketchy trade.
So it's totally honest with you.
And we anyway missed the boat.
Wait, no, we didn't.
How did we miss the boat?
What? Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Before we just, that's what we just took.
Before we actually just took this M15 cluster,
which I said is a little bit sketchy, but I'm, honestly, if price is going to
trade back below
this Asia low, then it's probably got a number one shift bearish and number two
.
Take the swing lows as well.
I did say it is a little bit unorthodox and I will flag it for review.
It is a little bit of an unorthodox trade, honestly.
Like I wouldn't be surprised if some, some intent of the M15 is open.
I wouldn't be surprised if some people didn't catch this.
I wouldn't even be surprised if those times were either.
Catch that to be totally honest.
I mean, the entire trade set up makes sense.
The only thing that doesn't make sense is the M1 structure, right?
And, well, the M1 structure, I don't know.
I don't know, I don't think there's too much wrong with it.
But I would have liked to go to break.
And technically, I can't 17th of November building permits.
I'm going to get some break here and just because you have the news.
Okay.
This is one that I will tag for review and I'll give a little bit of context.
So the context that we need to understand here is that.
[ Silence ]
But it, I mean, just play out our favor.
Point of interest.
I'm probably going to have to keep that void because it's after a
sweep, it's in London, structure flow.
I'm going to keep all that void.
The structure is.
Oh, that's not true.
[ Silence ]
Like, just FYI, I still consider this as a change of character.
Like, again, there's no M1 shifting site up until here.
So I would have had to wait for that to be shifted.
[ Silence ]
Or use this, which honestly, like, there's nothing wrong with using that as a
pulpit.
If there was another one, let's say, for example, here or here, sure.
Like, I'll probably just wait.
But it's also with a factor.
First footage candles here, we have a bunch of bullish candles.
They just don't break about each other.
But this candle here, like, there's a huge gap in this.
And then this candle.
This is very likely a, um, bullish candle.
Obviously, you can't really see it, but it's actually a neutral candle.
That's, I guess, the whole point of using it.
But the factor is price, closed, higher than this price.
So yeah, it's my, it's my opinion.
You can also look at this one as well.
This one doesn't have three candles for you.
And the entry is a little bit unorthodox.
I'm using the logic of, like, there's such a perfect sweep of Asian low
and the swing low.
Like, it's imminent reversal.
The, the, honestly, the full reality is that if price comes to this low,
it's taking this low as well.
And on the back of that, if price trades below this low,
there's a decent chance that it might close below this low.
Those indicate in a change of character,
those invalidate in the trade that I mean, anyway.
Right, it's not reckless.
I would have put the same context in if it would have went against me.
So.
Okay.
Can we get a shift?
Nope.
And.
Huh.
I actually didn't expect that.
I was just literally waiting for price to run through the low and give change
character.
Um, yeah.
That's what I'd be looking at.
Again.
I don't like the fact that we have to expand price so high, but yeah.
We do have FOMC.
Um, but it isn't now.
So we may get a bit of price tags in.
We move out.
We can at least move our stops below this low.
Like at least.
0.35% risk.
And that says stop loss.
And it's good management.
We're going to reduce and risk.
You know, probably not going to trade that, of course.
New York though.
Oh, no.
Still.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
No.
It's a new structural leg.
So it's no longer part of the age of session.
It's an entirely new structural leg.
8.30.
But then again, like.
Twenty second.
Yeah.
Droble goods.
The reality is, is like we still haven't taken age high.
This becomes a liquidity build up.
I want to see age high get taken into the matter anyway.
Um, a lot of liquidity.
It is the 23rd.
We have H cup.
So yeah.
And that's just as bullish.
And very unlikely we get trade.
Although apparently not that unlikely.
But there's not going to be an entry.
Oh, is there.
Oh, no.
Hang on a second.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's see.
5 minute.
Would I have taken it?
Yeah, probably.
On the M15, I probably would have just used the body.
And still.
Put my stops under here.
What's the risk to reward like.
Yeah.
I didn't expect it to give us confirmation to be honest with you.
Immediate risk reduction.
I'm not a huge fan of the trade anyway.
So basically going to break even.
It's very news after 23rd.
No.
Totally not.
5R.
And oh, my goodness.
Well, that would definitely be breaking even so.
Not yet.
Quite the ride that takes you for.
No.
Let's get half of that position at the table.
And nice full position.
London session.
The bullish Asian lows is the low.
New York.
No.
Still bullish.
28th.
Is so 28th.
We have nothing really.
There's probably a reversal there somewhere.
Apparently it's here.
Is it?
Yeah.
Interesting.
Invert if I wake up.
Not sure how this is going to play out to be honest with you.
It's only one to six.
But it's from a strong point of interest.
Tag.
Risk reduction.
Definitely I'm going to break even.
That's 5R.
Maybe I'm going to secure some partials.
Maybe not.
Yes.
No.
No, that was.
Hmm.
Perfect.
5R.
That's 5R.
Painful trade.
Just watching it up and down.
Psychologically.
That's a London sweet frank.
A really strong point of interest.
London session.
Structure flow is avoid.
Trend is.
Trender.
Yeah.
For your discount.
Owners.
Execution was three to four.
Really nice trade.
When is that 20 nights?
We have inflation rate GDP.
Come.
I mean.
Really weird price action.
But I did just take a trade similar to this.
Am I going to take every trade that.
Oh, wait.
Did I take a trade similar to this though?
Or was it actually?
It wasn't my one actually with larger.
Because that's actually two.
That's actually two.
There's not a gap above or a doge or something like that.
Like a neutral candle.
Like there's no candle that closed above it.
And again, like I said,
like it might end up being that I lose.
Not lose.
Like don't make money as a result.
It's just subjective.
We're bearish.
There's not going to be a trade.
It's a London.
We are.
The average, I believe.
Honestly, this type of price action I wouldn't be interested in.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
New York, probably no trade.
Nope.
And then you have it.
Ladies and gentlemen.
30% win rate is what we ended up on at the end.
91 trades in 2023.
We're going to be viewing a full detailed report,
78% return.
We're going to look at a full detailed in-depth report.
In an individual video.
But that is our full 2023 complete.
That's 2023, 2024, and 2025.
35% win rate, 36% win rate, 35% win rate,
which gives us an average of 111 by three.
Don't mind my maths.
That's given 33%.
All right, I will assume.
Of course, how's that possible?
35, 36, 30, oh, terrible maths.
Yeah, 33% win rate.
33% win rate, solid.
A lot of refinements to do as well.
In total, we have 100, 200,
and 22, 30, 200, 31 trades.